en el 2013 regrese a colombia después de
12 años por fuera
después del doctorado después de
estudiar muchos años
y empecé a hacer un trabajo de campo que
me cambió la vida estábamos haciendo una
investigación sobre el empoderamiento de
la mujer queríamos saber cómo las
mujeres podían ganar más ingresos podían
ser emprendedoras y son mujeres en
situación de violencia y víctimas del
conflicto armado víctimas de violencia
doméstica o en pobreza extrema
porque me cambió la vida esta es una
foto en siloé
yo soy de cali con cable como rola y
recuerdo mucho muchas de esas historias
porque si lo es es un lugar muy
vulnerable de la ciudad donde crecí en
donde nací
recuerdo a mariah que decía que ella no
podía salir a buscar un trabajo porque
el novio de su mamá había violado a su
hija de 7 años recuerdo a rosario que
decía que no podía salir a trabajar
porque el tío había tratado de usar de
su hija pero también recuerdo otras
historias de empoderamiento por ejemplo
en bogotá en el codito en donde una
desplazada del conflicto con la plata
que recibió el gobierno se había
comprado una lavadora después 16
lavadoras y en el momento en que
hablamos con ella tenía un negocio de
lavadoras portátiles y con eso sostenía
su familia y a cinco hijos
durante ese tiempo me di cuenta del
poder que podían tener las mujeres para
transformar su propia vida y que más
allá de un programa del gobierno que
funcione
o que no funcione tenemos competencias
blandas tenemos característica
resiliencia y que hacen que unas mujeres
puedan salir adelante y que otras no en
ese momento no entendía bien qué era lo
que pasaba pero después empecé a
trabajarlo desde mi fundación
para los investigadores las mujeres
somos eso de estadísticas
yo soy economista y siempre me preocupé
por entender las estadísticas y no por
entender a profundidad las relaciones
humanas y por eso fue que escuchar a 93
mujeres durante ese trabajo de campo me
cambió la vida en colombia 67 por ciento
de las mujeres participan en el trabajo
en el mercado laboral mientras que 80%
de los hombres lo hacen
ganamos menos y la situación es muy
diferente para las mujeres que tenemos
el privilegio de estudiar y de vivir en
las ciudades por cada 1.000 pesos que
gana un hombre una mujer gana 800 pesos
la situación es muy diferente en zonas
rurales en donde una mujer gana
solamente 520 pesos por cada 1.000 pesos
que gana un hombre
colombia es el segundo país con más
mujeres en cargos de gerencia media y la
oit lo celebra
el 53.1 por ciento de las de los cargos
de gerencia media en colombia están
controlados por mujeres pero esa no es
la situación de los cargos de liderazgo
en colombia las mujeres sólo ocupamos el
12.1 por ciento de los cargos de
liderazgo
en cuanto a los emprendimientos la
situación no es diferente solamente 35
por ciento de las firmas tienen a
mujeres como sus dueños y esto va
empeorando a medida que las empresas van
creciendo entonces por ejemplo las
grandes empresas de más de 100 empleados
solamente 15.7 por ciento de las mujeres
son dueños de las empresas y el peor de
todos
solamente ocupamos 10% de las sillas de
las juntas directivas que en realidad
son las que toman las grandes decisiones
sobre las empresas
de dónde viene todo este interés de lo
social
mi abuelo que murió hace unos años en lo
que yo llamo comunista de escritorio una
de esas personas que hablaba de la
revolución pero que nunca se sentó a
hacerla pero dejó una gran semilla en mí
y en mi familia esa esa conciencia de lo
social esa conciencia de las
desigualdades y esa conciencia del
privilegio del privilegio que tengo por
haber nacido en una familia de clase
media en una zona urbana en cali por
haber ido un colegio privado por haber
tenido el apoyo que tuve mi familia
y esto se conecta con mi propósito de la
igualdad de género
hace unos años mi mamá me pidió que
limpiara mi cuarto del que me fui hace
muchos años y encontré un diario con
poemas y prosas
en esos poemas encontré una prosa sobre
el segundo sexo hoy que leído a simone
de beauboir y que me considero una
feminista economista entendí que a los
14 años sin llamarme feminista estaba
escribiendo sobre el segundo sexo y
solamente hasta que tuve 30 años y
llegué hasta trabajo de campo en zonas
rurales y urbanas en colombia me di
cuenta realmente
de las desigualdades de género sobre
todo de las mujeres más vulnerables y
como yo podía trabajar desde mi
privilegio para ayudar a empoderar las
no es mi culpa que nací en una familia
de clase media en donde me pudieron
pagar un buen colegio y que pudieron
ayudar a francia a los 18 años pero sí
es mi responsabilidad trabajar para que
esas mujeres puedan tener parte de ese
privilegio que yo tuve en la vida y eso
es lo que he estado haciendo desde el
2015 cuando empecé una fundación que se
llama corvo man en donde trabajamos para
darle ese poder a las mujeres nadie le
nadie en realidad nadie puede darle el
poder pero facilitar para que las
mujeres tomen ese poder
esta soy yo a los 5 años
yo era modelo
me parezco mi familia me ha molestado
mucho porque todas mis fotos desde mis 3
a mis siete años estoy posando lo que yo
veo en esa foto es una niña con un muy
alto nivel de autoconfianza una niña que
recibió mensajes muy positivos una niña
a la que después los mensajes negativos
podrían transformar la cuales esos
cuáles fueron esos mensajes que recibí
las invitó y los invitó a pensar también
esos mensajes que recibí de mi mamá de
mi papá de mis tías de mis tíos de mis
abuelos de las monjas del colegio del
sagrado corazón de jesús de cali de
todas las personas que me rodeaban en
ese momento
entonces que recuerdo a veces no tiene
los mensajes negativos primero me decían
no seas tan mandón cita esas eran mis
días tan creída
está claro si me ven así esto debe decir
que está increíble
tan metida grande porque yo quería tener
conversaciones con los adultos porque
eres tan rebelde de chiquitas nos están
diciendo que no podemos ir en contra de
las normas sociales y si lo hacemos
porque tan rebelde debes aprender a ser
más suave eres muy dura desde pequeños
nos están diciendo que tenemos que
conformarnos con las normas sociales en
donde se espera que las niñas sean
suaves y se comportan como princesas y
no se revelen o agarrate sea afro yo soy
crespo y en cali bueno entonces agárrate
ese afro
también recibí mensajes muy positivos
eres muy inteligente escribes muy bien
yo leía mucho leo mucho vas a llegar muy
lejos debe ser una mujer independiente
económicamente muchos de estos mensajes
dados por mi mamá que hoy está acá
presente y después cuando ustedes
escuchan estos mensajes y cuando yo
recuerdo sus mensajes me pongo a pensar
como en sus mensajes me empoderan o me
quitan el poder como esos mensajes
salen de mi cabeza y se vuelven una
especie de crítica interna que me
paralizan cuando yo quiero jugar en
grande cuando quiero salirme mi zona de
confort estudios han demostrado
que las mujeres tienen mayor aversión al
riesgo todas las mujeres menos mi madre
pero en general todas las mujeres las
mujeres tienen menor probabilidad de
pedir un un crédito para iniciar sus
negocios las mujeres tenemos una brecha
en la autoconfianza cuando un hombre un
hombre aplica un trabajo cuando siente
que cumple el 60 por ciento de las
referencias del trabajo y una mujer
cuando cumplimos el 100% pero de dónde
vienen esas brechas de la autoconfianza
de estos mensajes de la crítica interna
esos mensajes se vuelven voces y nos
empiezan a decir tú no puedes no seas
tan mandón cita porque eres tan creída
si yo trato de visualizar me en mí en mi
trabajo esa vocecita que en mi caso el
hada de mis tías ya que me dice por qué
eres tan creída y dejamos de visibilizar
los y eso nos va a afectar en nuestra
vida laboral y en nuestra vida como
emprendedores
a raíz de esto empezamos en la fundación
de nuestra fundación core woman a
trabajar con dibujos y quería contarle
la historia de los dibujos porque es el
instrumento la herramienta más poderosa
que hemos encontrado para trabajar esos
mensajes esas voces internas y al final
son la forma como nos socializaron y
también las voces que nos paran nos
paralizan
estos son ejemplos de dibujos y
trabajamos estos dibujos en diferentes
lugares desde el putumayo en zonas
rurales mujeres víctimas del conflicto
armado y de violencia sexual por actores
del conflicto en colombia hasta mujeres
emprendedoras en bogotá mujeres
corporativas de multinacionales en nueva
york' y en miami y hemos encontrado
tendencias muy parecidas diferentes
según el nivel socioeconómico y si
estamos en áreas rurales o urbanas
siempre trabajamos en el lado izquierdo
los mensajes negativos y en el lenguaje
en la parte derecha los lenguajes
positivos estos son ejemplos por ejemplo
de mujeres hicieron este ejercicio hace
dos meses en el putumayo
y acá tengo más dibujos
hemos encontrado una categorización de
los tipos de mensajes que escuchamos por
ejemplo mensajes sobre nuestro carácter
tú puedes eres una dura me encanta tu
energía un mensaje negativo es como eres
una regañona eres una mandona eres muy
tímida qué pasa con las mujeres una vez
salimos al mercado laboral y salimos de
las instituciones educativas en donde
estamos protegidas y escuchamos esos
mensajes o recordamos esos mensajes
entonces si a mí me decía cuando yo
estaba pequeña que era muy regañona o
que era muy mandona yo me voy a esconder
y esto explica parte de la brecha de
liderazgo que les contaba ahora
solamente 12.1 por ciento de las mujeres
de los cargos de liderazgo en colombia
en este momento son ocupados por mujeres
entonces si a esa niña que veían antes
le decían eres muy dura eres muy mandona
esa niña se empieza a esconder esa niña
deja de mostrar sus habilidades esa niña
deja de ser asertiva y deja de mostrar
para lo que es buena los estudios
demuestran que las mujeres tienen mayor
problema de visibilizar sus habilidades
cuántas de ustedes se sienten
identificadas pero si un hombre dice yo
soy buenísimo para esto yo sé hacer este
power point dice hacer la estrategia de
la empresa si una mujer dice exactamente
lo mismo dicen que la mujer tan creída
si un hombre dice exactamente lo mismo
dice él es un líder asertivo entonces
como la sociedad nos juzga de diferente
manera y nos dice estos mensajes
diferentes nos empezamos a esconder y
eso explica las brechas de liderazgo
encontramos también mensajes sobre
nuestro aspecto físico eres muy flaca
eres negrita de la familia y ahora es
adoptada cuando tengas 18 años te
mandamos a operar la nariz de hecho ese
último es mío a los 13 años primero que
ese homenaje y después crecido
y tuve muchos traumas con la todavía no
acepto mucho nunca me operado la nariz
es tan natural pero todos sus mensajes
relacionados a nuestro color de piel al
racismo a la forma como nos vemos se ve
reflejado después en ciudades como cali
en las cirugías plásticas que se hacen
las mujeres y se quedan en nuestro
subconsciente encontramos muchos
mensajes sobre nuestro potencial o que
validan esa potencial y nos invitan a
ser mejores o que nos reprimen y está
muy relacionado con el nivel
socioeconómico por ejemplo no puedes
depender de un hombre eso lo escuché
muchas veces y tuve el ejemplo de una
mujer empresaria que no dependía de un
hombre vas a llegar muy lejos pero
también mensajes como tu hermano si
puede y tú no o mejor que un hombre tema
y esos mensajes se quedan en nuestro
subconsciente y en la edad adulta
actuamos en ellos o mensajes también
como las expectativas hacia las mujeres
que son diferenciadas con las
expectativas que se tienen de un hombre
a nosotras nos dicen todo tiene que ser
perfecto y resulta que cuando somos
emprendedoras nos cuesta muchísimo
arrancar porque nunca nada está perfecto
cuando estamos haciendo un
emprendimiento cuando yo estaba
iniciando por woman estaba en crisis
porque yo creía que necesitaba un
doctorado en psicología y mi doctorado
ahora de economía entonces nada va a
estar perfecto podemos armar equipos
esto es muy peligroso para una mujer nos
están diciendo desde pequeñas que hay
cosas que las mujeres no pueden hacer
cuantas veces yo he visto y de pronto
ustedes han visto mamá diciéndole a una
niña chiquita no corras no hagas no te
subes al árbol no te ensucies el vestido
desde chiquitos no se están socializando
para ser princesas perfectas y todo no
lo decía abrir las nuevas generaciones
tienen otro tipo de socialización pero
yo vi cenicienta y blancanieves y lo que
me estaba enseñando era que un príncipe
azul iba a ser a practicar acoso sexual
tanto el peso a una princesa sin su
consentimiento y salvarla en sus sueños
eso fue lo que nos enseñaron las
películas ahora tenemos a moulin ya
frozen pero a las de 36 nuestro para
otro tipo de películas entonces estos
son los mensajes que nos estaban dando y
los mensajes que nos llegan en nuestra
cabeza y que podemos ver por medio de
los dibujos este es parte del equipo de
por broma y el corvo man hacemos siempre
este ejercicio en nuestro programa
auto-confianza y crítica interna y yo
las invito y los invito porque los
patrones de esos
que nos afectan para jugar en grande no
solo nos afectan a las mujeres nosotros
trabajamos con las mujeres porque
queremos cerrar una brecha pero los
hombres también son víctimas de un
proceso de socialización que no los deja
llorar que les dice tienes que ser un
machito que no puede sentir que no
puedes que no necesariamente si puedes
cuidar a tus hijos porque entonces vas a
hacer menos hombres menos mal esto está
cambiando poco a poco
entonces los invito y los invito a que
hagan este ejercicio como lo hacemos
cogen un papel unos lápices de colores y
se imagina si se pintan
en un lado van a escribir esos mensajes
que recibieron cuando eran pequeños o
cuando estaban creciendo de su mamá de
su papá de sus tíos del colegio yo por
ejemplo de las monjas de las tías de los
compañeros de la universidad acuérdense
esos mensajes que mensajes eran
negativos qué mensajes eran positivos y
después hacemos una reflexión de cómo
esos mensajes algunos de esos mensajes
se vuelven voces voces que nos paralizan
o voces que nos dan poder cuando
identificamos a esas voces que nosotros
le decimos la crítica interna con base
en un libro recomendado de dar amor que
se llama plane bitch
hacemos un ejercicio de trabajar con la
crítica interna la crítica interna o
esas voces que en mi caso yo visualice
como las voces de mis días
salen en cada momento que nos salimos de
nuestra zona de confort el día que yo
decidí ser emprendedor a esas voces me
dijeron tú no eres capaz el día que yo
empecé a hablar más en público y am a
visualizar me esas bolsas me decías me
decían no te muestres no seas creída el
día que yo empecé a liderar equipos esa
voz a me decían no seas tan mandón cita
pero esas voces siempre salen cuando
salimos de nuestra zona de confort y lo
que podemos aprender es manejarlas para
que no nos paralizan y para que podamos
jugar en grande nos podemos concentrar
en las voces empoderado horas y para
terminar un mensaje muchas de nosotras y
estamos acá tenemos ciertos privilegios
algunas nacimos en clase media en clase
alta fuimos a colegios privados o
públicos pero somos muy privilegiadas
solamente por estar el hecho por el
hecho de estar acá parte de nuestro
privilegio en el empoderamiento de la
mujer es trabajar con otras mujeres es
ayudar a otras mujeres por medio de
mentorías escuchando dejando de competir
y trabajando en círculos de mujeres para
para ayudarnos entre nosotras reconocer
que podemos usar nuestro privilegio para
ayudar a otras mujeres gracias
[Aplausos]